[Music]
a massive container ship blocking one of
the world's busiest shipping routes
could take
weeks to move the vessel ran aground in
egypt's suez canal more than two days
ago and you can even see from space
how the ship is jammed against the walls
of the canal stopping traffic in both
directions word is it's as long as the
empire state building is tall
it's ginormous elizabeth palmer is
tracking the latest developments from
tel aviv
this is a real monster of a problem
the ever givens owners say a gust of
wind pushed it and its huge
cargo of containers sideways and now
it's stuck
heavy equipment has been working day and
night to free it
and as long as it's in the way with
other ships piling up behind it it's
holding up
ten percent of the world's trade at
thirteen hundred feet the ever given is
almost as long as the empire state
building or chicago's willis tower are
tall
wedged across a canal just half that
size
diggers have been clearing sand away so
at high tide tugboats can try to pull it
free
if that doesn't work salvage crews may
drain its fuel tanks to make it lighter
but then there's a risk of capsizing the
ship
actually is a marine
underwriter in tel aviv we are talking
about a
very accurate navigation it's like a
brain surgery the beam of the boat is 50
meter
means you have 25 meter
to play with so there was no wiggle room
no not at all the ever given blockage
creates
a dilemma for ships wait and hope that
it's refloated
fast maybe by unloading some of those
containers
or go the very long way round
around magazine
south africa and all the way
to europe a long way to go
it could mean a serious slowdown in
goods moving to europe and the u.s
in a system already under strain from
the pandemic
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in tel aviv
that's that's a long way around the long
way is a very long way that must have
been a heck of a win though to do that i
know curious what did that look like
i